hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things in the night my
name is Mark Byron we just got out of
the deep cellar from the water that
whispering is so creepy
ooh okay anyway I've got I'm making a
small change so what I've done before
which is I've got I've got the sound
turned way up in my headphones I can
barely hear myself talk at all okay
anyway I got one half of the acid
mixture and I've got two of three fuel
rods that says explode again alright I
can't hear a damn thing so I can't hear
myself talk turn that down a bit
anywho got these little rods on the jam
them in these holes yeah yeah wait was
that the right one okay
probably okay anyway so where in the
world do I find the last one that is the
question and a good question it is okay
so I've been in the other area than the
other
wait a minute oh wait no maybe I'm wrong
oh wait no yes yes go
[Music]
oh by the way um something cool happened
just recently the maker of this mod
actually contacted me and thanked me for
playing it and so I got an opportunity
to really tell them how much I
appreciate this this great great mod
that he made I mean really like this is
one of the best I've ever seen so it's
pretty darn good I'm out of oil ah crap
I forgot I'm completely out of oil so
yeah it was really cool that he actually
took the time to come to me so I told
them that you know pretty soon I'm sure
that this mod will get extremely popular
because all the other let's players will
want to play it because it's just it's
phenomenal and he said that I he was
surprised because I rarely got stuck and
he said the only reason that I didn't
get stuck is haha Helio is because I
actually read the notes I think I
remember someone commenting that there
was another room over here ah these
looks about right
the cotton candy the dripping Cup and
candy you heard me uh someone exploded
all over the place
they're nervous some people how dare
they leave their guts just lying around
I can't see anything I know I just got
oil but trying to be conservative okay
here we go this is something here
I guess I'm supposed to do something oh
the acid mixture probably comes you know
what's this nope ow my heart whatever I
would assume that there would be some
other type of the other part of the ask
mixer here I do not see it really that
hurt that bad are you kidding me
geez it's just some ass get over
yourself you're such a douche a pansy
douche okay see it anything it was like
supposed to be a rod here let me check
my notes again yeah I think I found
anything too recently when is it my best
drawer I got that one found the key I
can't find her Oz just ask maintenance
where the rest of them are so maybe
there's another note from some guys in
maintenance somewhere
girl her I was sure that this room would
lead me to some goodies
oh well it happens who knows what okay I
thought that was gonna leave me
somewhere good but maybe there are some
other rooms in here that I've missed I'm
pretty sure there's got to be be very
very careful about my oil consumption
Donna any buying here I think of are
checked things reset when you leave and
exit
shut up don't cares about you moaning I
hear it dark is like super dark nothing
nothing
I didn't think I missed anything when I
came back here I've already checked all
those desk drawers yeah BAM this was
locked I can't exactly get anything
there's that big bucket acid what do I
do about that
Your Honor Bergen feigl bring a [ __ ]
Fraggle well I guess you know I've been
going through the game pretty smoothly
so far so so many whispers down the
hallway hot fun not fun fun okay so
maybe okay let me just check back
oh they check back in here one of these
no no back there the wall still eat
barrels yep it do okay but that's not my
main concern
God seriously I'm trying to be really
sparing about my oil use but it's still
just brains like right away let me check
these rooms again very careful snooze a
chair this was where the key was
why dear okay I don't know why I gotta
do that face with the two but it's just
it goes hand in hand you can't do one
without the other
[Music]
I'm really in a pickle I don't know it
is Rowdy
blood oh this is where I skillfully
dodged another one of the monsters this
is where I found the first rod which is
behind all the books here
[Music]
nope nope no no all lies just like wait
this whole levels of big fat lie lies
everywhere okay there's nothing in here
I checked here I have a check to there
I've checked just about everywhere this
this um store across the way this gate
is what thing I'm supposed to try to
home
okay what okey-dokey I thought that was
the door I needed all three rods to go
through oh the ceiling dripping blood
those are right torch aside oh but they
don't go very far down there wow those
are like super bright stupid bright oh
hello hey buddy how you doing oh I see
why it's dripping blood that would
explain it
oh so bright that's like crazy bright
hurts my eyeballs
the monster gonna come popping out of
here yes
oh okay there we go okay that's all I
need that's plenty of light that's crazy
amounts of light right
[Music]
hey secrets up there something nope
Oh lies all lies I'm surrounded by liars
potatoes ah too many whispers pigs
oh I don't like this I don't like this
at all
I'm out of oil my piggy
hey piggies that's going pigs I don't
know where I'm going or what I'm doing I
might have broken the game or something
I don't know down here okay oh that's
not oil that's oil okay here we go
anything in there I can't pull those
books out there there we go some lowdown
on them is this let me clear this out
just case the monster comes by which is
always probable Wow nice front flip okay
whatever I don't see anything else of
import here not even a note ah what
right oh yeah
lab key I've done the actual lab key
it's the key to the lab where this guy's
dad is isn't it that's a lab key right
cool
awesome monster
God God Oh
pigs just swinging in the wind nothing
scary about that
Oh God that whispering is like gonna
drive me insane
seriously okay
another door over here - okay
I'll assume there's nothing else right
[Music]
right right I still got the music like
turned up way loud in my headphones here
I can't help but feel I may have bug
some things out there like what was the
acid for I've totally forgotten
oh that's that was the bun when it was
four I was supposed to get the acid to
burn through the of the stuff down there
to get the last rod but but bad okay
don't matter I got the lab keys those
always there I think so
smoke coming through the floor nothing
happened I totally expected monster to
come pouring out of the walls but I'm
guessing they should have
[Music]
I don't know framers there we go hey bro
you out here bro ham her no okay so I
guess I'm just gonna head down to the
lab and open it up and confront my
father foshan because I am assuming
that's all there is to it right right
right
okay actually I'm gonna hold off on this
until the next zone episode because I'm
right out of time and this might be
close to the ending I'm not sure so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part bye bye